[Music]
when you're blending PS will be a
pharmacy harmony is ago I think we are
more perfectionist than our competitors
if I can say so
this is why we need to eat every morning
in this room because there's a lot to
taste many samples every day when making
VSOP everything is linked together if
you achieve all the different levels
then you get to perfect VSOP the
variables they start with how you manage
your vineya every needs to bring an
expertise around the cognac making
process what I mean by that is one is in
charge of managing the distillation so
his expertise is in distillation another
one is explicit in managing the bowels
and aging process so you've got a
question about you can ask him directly
blending is not the touch that makes
everything different it's the the end of
a long and continuous process we taste
around 10,000 samples every year when
you start you you journey in this room
the first 10 years of your life
basically mouth shut you listen and you
learn from the order and the fact that
we've got people from different
generations it's also a way to be able
to be consistent for the future to
prepare the future
[Music]
anywhere you go in the world when you
open a bottle of any CVS Opie you will
find the same balance the same how many
you don't do that
bye-bye chains company you build it you
don't it's not just like it's not magic
[Music]